[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait ce sport par ce temps glacial je
vous propose de passer une heure avec
nous bien au chaud devant votre écran le
programme nous allons parler évidemment
de l'actualité du sport yvelinois local
yvelinois quatre chroniqueurs vont
m'accompagner aujourd'hui dans cette
émission
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite qui ne vous laissera pas de glace
j'en suis sûre quand il est sur la piste
du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on le surnomme
le blizzard il sera notre spécialiste
cyclisme aujourd'hui le capitaine
dujarrier du club de vélizy 78 est avec
nous tout joueur c'est cela c'est au
tournant de quoi le capitaine le
capitaine khalid gueddar visage le
bizarre moi j'espère que je suis moins
moins froid qu'il y ait en paraît et
j'espère que je ne donne pas cette
impression justement de froideur
en tout cas vous avez réussi à venir
malgré des conditions climatiques
compliquées
mon vélo passe partout on passe de
l'autre côté musique c'est notre reine
des neiges annuel souffle le chaud et le
froid chaque semaine sur les barres de
pole dance son sport de prédilection
notre ambassadrice de charme notre
flocons hélène de la grange est avec
nous pendant une heure eva je suis ravi
et notre flocons c'est mignon j'aime
bien je deviens très bien j'aime bien
mais vous êtes arrivée jusqu'ici
et oui j'ai réussi j'ai réussi j'ai dû
me radier quand même pour venir mais
je suis pas mis en tenue de pole dance
de pole dance alors je pouvais pas la
tronche on passe de l'autre côté à
musique vous le connaissez tous
ils errent dans les rues de versailles
seulement vêtu d'une peau de bête en
plein hiver sous la neige
aujourd'hui chez par décence pour vous
chers téléspectateurs il est venu en
costume notre gladiateurs pire
chevallier de rugby club de versailles
est avec nous salut michael
effectivement à rien de ma billes
je vais garder mon traîneau et mes
chiens en double file devant et voilà
présents dont bab batteux peaux de bêtes
aujourd'hui
pas de peaux de bêtes gl est un petit
peu humide depuis hier soir donc je les
remises et des chemines titre est une
prochaine fois peut-être
voilà je vous la rapporte on termine de
l'autre côté musique on a de la chance
de l'avoir sur ce plateau avec nous car
il souffre de kyo nos phobies la peur de
la neige et l'accueil au cfaa robbie la
peur des boules de neige comme mais il a
décidé de venir en luge aujourd'hui pour
vaincre vaincre ses phobies genlis et
avec une bonne sort quand allez vous
gérer elle est très bien très bien j'ai
un petit peu de mal à dire un genou
devra en outre l'apport des boules donc
de neige je vous donnais les boules de
neige bien sûr non mais c'est très très
bien j'ai fait j'ai fait un bonhomme de
neige d'ailleurs ce matin pour vaincre
votre phobie juste mais justement
mauvais la fouille la phobie mais bon
j'avais j'avais tout prévu j'avais sorti
du chapeau légal écharpe
le ballet et tout c'est quand j'ai sorti
la carotte
là je me suis je dit m mais sinon tout
va bien un jour me sens en grande forme
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler automobile et de tristan
couëdel qui vient de terminer le rallye
et africa eco race nous ferons également
un coup de projecteur sur le i ce porte
le tournoi de houston était organisée à
versailles mais avant de développer ces
thèmes on va parler de cyclisme
[Musique]
troisième finale de la coupe d'hiver au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la compétition organisée le dimanche 27
janvier regroupé cette année huit clubs
franciliens de la catégorie minime aux
élites
l'événement est en pleine expansion
allait passer de 90 à plus de 130
participants depuis sa création
on écoute l'un des organisateurs jean
michel richefort au micro de tv 78 ça
fait partie des objectifs de beaucoup de
coureurs et de beaucoup de pistard et
cette coupe d'hiver fait partie de deux
d'une très bonne préparation et pour
certains ils vont attaquer les épreuves
sur route notamment les coureurs
d'endurance pour attaquer les épreuves
sur route dans un mois et donc c'est une
excellente préparation et la piste parmi
ces coureurs présents 24 féminine sur la
piste une première pour l'événement
marine cloirec du club de puteaux n'a
pas hésité à participer à ce rendez vous
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines pour promouvoir le cyclisme
sur piste féminin
ça nous permet de nous mettre en avant
et de voir que le cyclisme féminin
attend de voir que le cyclisme féminin
faire de la piste et que voilà on est on
a quand même un niveau et que on a notre
place dans le cycle i dans le cyclisme
sorti la question sur ce thème cette
compétition doit-elle être pérennisé
dans le temps oui ou non
c'était la troisième édition parce qu'il
en faut une quatrième une cinquième une
6ème 7ème une dixième peut-être un jour
oui pour tout le monde genre pourquoi
ben il nomme une compétition à nouveau
une compétition quelqu'un soit vous
qu'elle soit pérennisée
ça va de soi plus il ya de sport au
mieux c'est d'autant plus que là on est
en constante progression au niveau des
participants
90 4 sera parti bien écoutez donc voilà
donc que ces baisses c'est insidieux ça
veut tout simplement dire que de plus en
plus de compétiteurs qui s'engagent à là
dessus comme ça c'est un point positif
et en aucun cas en dehors elle a un
nouvel arrêté de la question d'ailleurs
de se poser par hélène vous aussi vous
aimez cette compétition oui je rejoins
son avis je pense que les entraînements
c'est bien mais la compétition c'est
beau c'est d'un autre niveau
yann le disait justement à la précédente
émission plus je pense que quand on est
on donne pas la même chose quand on est
en compétition que quand on est en
entraînement c'est l'occasion de se
mesurer en plus c'est le cyclisme
féminin donc ça ne va pas
24e minute ouais bah ce qui est énorme
dans une compétition comme ça c'est
voilà c'est alors on a continué à
comment dire à faire grandir en nombre
et puis en notoriété donc pour moi oui à
pérenniser longtemps pierre chevallier
c'est un vrai plus certains voient un
vrai plus les le cycliste fait partie de
ces rares sports qui ont qui ont un
intérêt en outdoor et en indoor et la
pouvoir pouvoir promouvoir le cyclisme
sur le vélodrome de saint quentin en
plein hiver quand quand la plupart des
autres sports notamment collectif se les
ont froid c'est une très bonne chose
pour justement la promotion et notamment
quand on peut quand on peut aussi faire
la promotion du sport féminin en même
temps que celui des garçons c'est une
c'est une excellente chose de pouvoir
attirer de plus en plus de monde sur une
activité sportive comme comme on irait
au cinéma ou au bowling se mettre au
chaud il ya du jarrier vous y étiez vous
sur cette compétition mais pas vous
n'avez pas forcément brillé 1
il faut le dire et pas toujours être
nous en dire un peu plus
cette première chose je voudrais juste
les images de la vraie course ce ne sont
pas une nuit cours
ce ne sont pas huit clubs qui se
rencontrent sinon ce sera la nature club
on vous voit vous va me faire trembler
les coller tout va bien c'est ce sont
huit clubs qui se réunissent pour
organiser cette compétition il ya cinq
compétitions cas dans quatre contre
quatre ou cinq compétitions pendant la 2
novembre jusqu'à jusqu'à janvier et
ensuite on fait une finale
en fait on fait du mal
on fait une finale vision laisser le
second centre oui parce que là vous
allez perdre mon jeu car mon fils
d'ailleurs les faits je vous ai montré
la lune donc voilà c'est vrai que moi ce
type de compétition reste dans un esprit
amical
voilà mais il y avait des compétiteurs
de toute la france il y avait des
compétiteurs qui est du nord pas de
calais il y avait des compétiteurs de
normandie il y en avait d'autres de
vendée donc voilà ça ça se déplace il ya
un vrai intérêt à vrai attrait
parce que venir courir sur le vélodrome
nationale je pense que l'on proposerait
à n'importe quel compétiteur de rugby
d'aller faire un stage à marcoussis il
serait il serait partant tout de suite
d'aller un footballeur d'aller à
clairefontaine ce serait ce serait une
chose donc voilà là on est dans l'antre
du cyclisme national et c'est vrai que
c'est l'apport du cachet oui voilà ça
donne envie de venir de venir courir
mais le gros problème que l'on a c'est
que ça coûte très très cher d'organiser
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il faut savoir que c'est une structure
qui à la même réglementation que le
stade de france en termes de sécurité et
donc à chaque fois que vous organisez un
évènement au vélodrome mais il faut
mettre des en place dès des agents de
sécurité et ce à un coût qui est je vais
donc plus de location voilà donc c'est
un coût qui est quand même assez assez
important et c'est la problématique qui
que l'on rencontre quand on veut
organiser des événements sur sur le vélo
sur le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
maintenant maintenant moi je suis je
suis super fan j'ai pu discuter dimanche
et même hier à l'entraînement avec le
ctr
qui est tout nouveau depuis le segment
très 2
alors c'est le voile a concédé contre
arsenal et donc qui a quitté tout
nouveau cap très bonne idée c'était un
ancien c'est un ancien entraîneur
d'endurance de l'équipe de france qui
est repassé sur la région ile de france
et c'est vrai qu'il a une vision qui a
été plutôt intéressante on a fait un
tournoi de vitesse qui était un peu
innovant on est sortis de des schémas
classiques histoire que après le 200 m
les qualifications soit fait que l'on
puisse courir entre coureurs de même
niveau et donc du coup plus de tomber
sur des gros et donc de ne pas pouvoir
faire un match qui servent à quelque
chose
voilà on a fait un très beau tour voir
ce qu'ils ont fait de cette semaine de
fin ce week-end pour pour tous les
compétiteurs c'est super d'avoir de
pouvoir faire trois manches différentes
sur une même journée on a vu très belle
course avec une belle densité et c'est
vrai que
enfin moi j'aime beaucoup regarder la
course des 1re caté sas a envoyé très
très fort et
à des femmes des faits marquants sur les
épreuves de qualification on a eu arnaud
démare qui s'est déplacé et qui est venu
courir il ya une quinzaine de jours donc
voilà même des prêts à démarrer les
affiches de ces dix mesures sur route
sèche et à la ldj qui est qui qui est un
garçon qui gagne l'étape sur tour de
france qui gagne des étapes toute
l'année sur route et donc voilà bah il
ça montre que les épreuves sur piste ont
un vrai un vrai intérêt est jolie mais
j'ai pu en parler avec lui à
l'entraînement aussi il me dit
j'aimerais bien pouvoir intégrer la
structure nationale pour faire de la
poursuite mais les entraîneurs les
programmes ne sont pas toujours
compatibles pourrait laisser la parole
aux autres un petit peu il ya du fait
qu'il est passionné par le sujet lui
tient pas de souci le vélodrome ça a du
cachet de gens formés toujours bien sûr
quand même et puis pour une fois qu'il
ya du cyclisme parce que généralement
est ce qu avait du monde d'escrimé du
public
eh bien non non comme d'habitude à 300
personnes les 300 à 500 personnes
alors si la performance de vienne
dujarrier parce qu'il a esquivé la
question sur sa performance a fait
beaucoup parler dans les travées du
vélodrome parmi les 300 personnes qui
étaient présentes
un autre fait marquant a eu lieu sur la
piste quelques gouttes d'eau venue du
toit ont un peu perturbé la compétition
les organisateurs devait essuyer la
piste à chaque passage des coureurs
qu'est ce que vous en pensez pierre
chevalier c'est dire que le budget les
budgets sont sûrement difficile à
boucler et que moi je n'aime pas cette
vélo et fenêtres ou pas assez
d'événements n'ont pas assez de location
sur les gros événements qui attirent du
public parce que ça ça me permet
peut-être pas de faire face aux frais
généraux et aux frais d'entretien
on s'arrête dans la plupart des
structures des structures sportives
alors couverte a fortiori mais là quand
y est une notion danger de danger
supplémentaire de glissade à surveiller
de près hélène l'équipement a été
inauguré en 2014
je le rappelle
c'est à vieux après est ce que nos gants
c'est ce que l'intégralité des travaux
et tout ce qui avait été prévu a été
fait non mais parce que ces entreprises
ont réduit peut-être certains frais ou
alors on effectue spatiale conception
vient de jeunes et donc sur la toiture
je n'ai pas mis les pieds là haut mais
voilà certains tueur il ya un boulot
pour pouvoir fixer des journées donc
chercher de l'eau normalement il aurait
fallu mettre un jour pour ne pas clos
puisque filtrer et ça n'a pas été fait
donc aujourd'hui la problématique
qu'elle est que en effet il ya de plus
en plus de fuites sur sur le vélodrome à
chagny chaque séance où l'on vient on
voit de nouvelles petites statiquement
il ya dans laquelle j'appelle que le
besoin de la semaine de cinq ans jean va
être un lieu emblématique des jo de 2024
appareils parce que les ignorants du
grosbois doute c'est très très
regrettable c'est quand on boit encore
l'aude cycliste avec une affaire de
jouer je pense de toute façon c'est ici
qu'on arrive en 2024 ils ont quand même
au moins les moyens financiers de la
cpnsep financière des montagnes c'est
l'assurance qui sont pour la malfaçon
pierre chevalier il ya une décennal de
toute façon je pense et puis d'ici 2024
largement le temps de d'accorder les
violons entre les assureurs et les
maîtres d'oeuvre m le temps passe mais
oui c'est danser dans cinq ans mais les
premières fuites je suis plus à parution
4 les premières questions nous à lui
apparaître en 2016 je crois 2015 lors
des championnats du monde s'il ne
s'était pas testé pas des frites c'était
de la condensation à l'époque c'est la
condensation ce dvd
en tout cas mieux garnis mais rassure
les kiwaniens au louvre maintenant une
thématique sport automobile le pilote
illinois tristan couëdel originaire du
petit village de la rue a réussi à
terminer le rallye africain africa et
corey a rendez-vous qui propose un tracé
proche de l'ancien dakar
c'est une première pour tristan qui
avait déjà tenté sa chance sur le
paris-dakar on écoute sa réaction
l'arrivée à dakar sur la plage fait tout
oublier
après les jours on était long intense
on a fini beaucoup de spéciales de nuit
et pour résumer un petit peu on passait
entre 10 et 11 heures par jour dans la
voiture et entre 3 et 6 heures sous la
voiture en arrivant au bivouac puisque
comme on était parti sans assistance
voilà nous faisions nous mêmes notre
mécanique quoi et au classement général
tristan couëdel et son coéquipier
edouard signes ont réussi à terminer la
course à la 21e place et premiers de
leur catégorie
la question sur ce thème que doit-on
retenir de cette performance
vous pouvez noter sur vos petites
ardoises ce qu'on doit retenir cette
performance derrière vous et même moi je
ne retiens rien cher à coeur donc oui
oui
un coeur pour chacun de chercher à les
pousser l'afrique c'est retour en
afrique c'est on en avait parlé lors de
la présentation de la course c'est au
moment où le houleux s'appelle toujours
le dakar roule en argentine c'est c'est
une bonne chose de voir la leur le
rallye raid et la course automobile
revenir sur les magnifiques paysages
africains et qu'un yvelinois puisse
s'aligner terminée et terminer dans dé
bonnes à une bonne place c'est aussi une
très bonne chose pour la mise en avant
de ces de cette discipline notamment et
quand on regarde ces images ça rappelle
les grandes grandes heures du paris
dakar quand c'était sur le territoire
africain sur le sur un continent qui est
qui est fait pour la course pour la
construire à lirey dont l'avait on
l'avait dit on l'avait évoquée c'est
très agréable de revoir ces images à
genlis qu'est ce que vous en pensez
qu'est-ce que vous avez noté sur votre
ardoise rien je suis à l'école j'étais
comme ça déjà
je n'aurais jamais rien tout dans la
tête alors qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
arrive dans votre tête
il ya plein de choses il n'essaie pas
déjà rencontré lui est très très sympa
il était venu sur ce prêt est super
sympa et c'est une très belle
performance sportive parce qu'on ne sait
quand même que c'est ce genre de
compétition et c'est raide c'est très
très très difficile en plus sans
assistance mécanique
d'où la difficulté encore plus
importante
donc là on peut que tirer le chapeau
parce que franchement c'est vraiment des
heures et des heures et des heures et
des nuits courtes est vraiment avec une
fatigue étaient restées parfois jusqu'à
six heures après la course pour réparer
sa voiture sourit j'ai 100 par contre il
a pas dû oublier se brosser les dents
c'est fantastique c'est parce qu'il
avait le temps pendant son périple et
colgate ya j'ai marqué peu de moyens et
vos résultats
alternez a fait montre votre s'écrit
comme un cochon donc peu de moyens bons
résultats c'est vrai que terminé 21e et
premier de sa catégorie alors que on est
sans assistance et qu'on y passe
quelques heures quelques heures tous les
soirs pour pour remettre la voiture en
état pour pourra partir d'un matin
chapeau le rallye dakar est ce que les
coréens et plus facile que les anciens
paris dakar il ya un peu moins de
participants
oui mais moins de participants ça veut
pas dire que c'est plus facile les
conditions la course ça reste la même
qu'au classement que vous grimpez l'alpe
d'huez tout seul où vous la grimper à 10
vous grimpez l'alpe d'huez touquet donc
pour moi voilà après c'est simplement la
cu le les étapes sont plus faciles ou
pas c'est la seule chose la seule
inconnue que je n'ai pas sûr sur le sur
le sujet mais voilà c'est vrai que
pouvoir pouvoir terminer ce type de ce
type de rallye fait partie des rêves de
beaucoup beaucoup de gens j'imagine dont
je fais partie alors qu'est-ce qui est
le plus remarquable terminé 21e de la
course ou juste de terminer la course
est déjà terminé la course avec des
conditions pareilles déjà je pense que
c'est une grande fierté terminer la
course
déjà sans assistance on en parlait et
terminer avec un résultat pareil c'est
ces mêmes j'allais dire au delà de ses
espérances il l'espérait mais c'est
c'est remarquable mais vraiment pour moi
terminer une course pareille dans des
conditions et sans assistance et c'est
sacré performance e est vraiment parce
que c'est aussi ça peut-être l'esprit le
premier esprit du sport automobile
finalement quand on sait que maintenant
les formule 1 les voitures de rallye
sont en terre équipé avec une grosse
équipe derrière l'a finalement c'est
peut-être les sens de la course
automobile ce qui rejaillit à travers
tristan wade c'est la connaissent la
connaissance de la mécanique est et de
ce qu'on sait en faire en plus du
pilotage et de l'orientation versus ce
qui se fait en formule 1 a effectivement
avec avec la toute puissance de la
technique et de l'assistance justement
avec de nombreuses personnes au chevet
de ses bacs est là et dans des
territoires qui sont qui sont vierges
magnifique comme cela de pouvoir en plus
ça fait semer d'embûches là y'en a
vraiment partout quand on voit les quand
on voit les les matières sur lequel il
roule c'est c'est d'autant plus
remarquable d'avoir à d'avoir tout ça à
faire à la main et simplement avec la
connaissance de la mécanique est un bon
facteur chance aussi je pense et mais ça
en a cerné d'autant plus remarquable il
a préparé sa voiture pendant deux ans
pour petite précision il voir la mer de
sable
peut-être mais on va poser la question
alors vous pourriez tenter une
expérience comme celle-là et dujarrier
si je l'avais vu des moyens bien sûr
avec grand plaisir
c'est vraiment un truc et je sais un
plus avec qui je le ferai avec mon père
ça c'est je le pense que c'est quelque
chose paraissait force et c'est vrai je
pense ainsi c'est un cadeau que je
pouvais faire un jour à mon père ce
serait ça de lui dire papa on part faire
le haka
je pense qu'il serait qui serait aux
anges mais voilà mais c'est un
ça veut dire que je pars cet été en
namibie avec deux amis dont deux femmes
on aura des routes secours et cetera
mais on appareils camion tentes camping
mais ça va être dans le désert face à
des jours passent le no 2 suisse voilà
je pense que si on a besoin on appellera
également vers vu comment est-ce que de
se retrouver dans des situations un
petit peu un peu compliqué mais voilà je
penserai à lui qu'ils se débrouillent
nous enverrait les photos on peut partir
avec la photo pour on arrête de faire
chauffer la gomme on va parler
équitation dans notre focus du jour une
mauvaise nouvelle pour le monde de
l'équitation le jumping international de
versailles est officiellement annulée
le concours de saut d'obstacles 5
étoiles devait avoir lieu au mois
d'avril dans les écuries en face du
château organisé une première fois en
2017 puis annulée en 2018 foot de dates
disponibles
les organisateurs ont cette fois-ci
wauquiez une conjoncture actuelle
compliqué l'événement est donc reporté à
l'année prochaine si tous les éléments
sont réunis en 2010 est le rendez-vous
avait attiré les meilleurs cavaliers
mondiaux
la question sur ce thème faut-il annuler
cet événement définitivement pas de duel
il ya du mariage et du goûter
voilà je sache je suis dégoûté pour deux
raisons d'une part ce que je pense que
le cheval à sa place à versailles
première chose et deuxième chose c'est
que ça me donne un indicateur assez
mauvais pour les épreuves les épreuves
olympiques qu'ils devaient se dérouler
sur ce site et je trouve ça vraiment
dommage
voilà c'est tout je pense que je
comprends pas qu'on n'arrive pas sur un
lieu comme celui là on n'arrive pas à
créer le budget on n'arrive pas à donner
de la pérennité un événement qui qui se
doit de qui se doit d'être c'est tout
simplement dommage que raul soit pas là
pour nous donner des des banques est
vraiment là je moi quand j'ai quand j'ai
vu ça sur sur le conducteur j'étais moi
je suis dégoûté je trouve ça je trouve
ça vraiment dommage et et j'espère que
j'espère qu'ils vont regarder parce que
quand on passe la main sur deux années
je pense que ça va être vraiment
compliqué pour la suite
si c'est effectivement extrêmement
dommage je partage leurs vis-à-vis de la
vidéo viennent dans la mesure où en plus
le je trouve que le communiqué est la
raison invoquée est un petit peu light
un petit peu un petit peu suivis pendant
dix ans on compte tenu de la conjoncture
on sait pas si c'est économique si c'est
politique a priori c'est à dire l'art de
je sens que sa chance que ça se voit
liés au budget aux finances mais mais
effectivement un théâtre pareil un écrin
pareil pour un pour un jumping et des
dés des compétitions équestres à 5 ans
des jo avec un programme qui avait été
complet sur les trois journées
parce que comme dit m versailles est une
est une terre de cheval est hélas hélas
hélas le théâtre qu'il propose est
absolument fantastique quand on voit ces
images dans les écuries du roi en face
de la place d'armes c'est fantastique
comme comme décor donc j'ai du mal à
comprendre
j'ai du mal à comprendre quelles sont
les réelles raisons ou est ce qu'il ya
vraiment eu toutes les motivations
nécessaires et tout l'obstination
nécessaire pour pouvoir maintenir
maintenir cet événement est étalée us
est en tout cas jusqu'en décembre
janvier
on en avait parlé même dans les dents
les événements attendus
2019 attention donc là on va pouvoir
celui là on va pouvoir se la coller
derrière l'oreille et le problème c'est
que c'est malheureusement à la question
que vous posez non il faut pas il faut
pas le il faut pas l'annuler
définitivement mais effectivement après
2 après près deux le jamais deux sans
trois est un petit peu risqué donc c'est
vrai c'est c1 celle de mauvaise augure
pour la suite
pour cet événement hélène est ce que les
organisateurs se moque du public
finalement c'est un événement qui est
quand même très attendu je pense que
c'est pas forcément d'équitation à sa
place à verser est ce que finalement ils
les organisateurs se moque du public je
pense pas que ce soit une question de se
moquer du public mais plutôt de quelque
part pas respecter l'univers de
l'équitation qui a vraiment sa place ici
les comment dire les cavaliers aussi qui
attendait cet événement on disait deux
annulations
je suis pas sûr que tous les cavaliers
soit 100% partance il ya une édition
comment dire annoncé l'année prochaine
il y aura peut-être un preuve de
motivation ou de la musique amateur
annulé deux fois d'affilée sans pétition
en tout cas pour moi annulé sans donner
de vraies raisons et de raisons vraiment
détaillé cheval ans et pas vraiment sur
quel sur quoi est basée la décision de
l'annulation
moi ça me gêne un peu ça me gêne un peu
genre qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
je crois que tout a été dit autour de la
table je me mets en suisse et le mettre
à la place du cavalier pas du cheval
mais à la place du cavalier et je rejoue
un petit peu hélène parce que un
compétiteur lorsqu'il ya deux années
consécutives la compétition est annulé
en plus ça envoie un mauvais message
sa voix un très mauvais message est
alors je ne connais pas les plannings
des cavaliers mais si un compétiteur
fait son programme qu'on a la plupart
des sports individuels sur sa saison et
que ça fait deux saisons qui prévoit
dans son programme le jumping
international à versailles et qu'il est
annulé un bus pour des raisons c'est un
petit peu obscur quoi on n'a pas les
réelles raisons un jumping internet qui
était censé accompagner l'équitation
jusqu'aux jo de 2004 les images de la
candidature française de donc cessé même
à la 8c ça dépasse le le
ça dépasse au niveau du sport du sportif
parce que le message qu'on envoie même
au niveau des géo et du niveau
international ça fait pas du tout
sérieux de la part de notre pays quoi
pour dans une discipline qui nous
rapportent des médailles et sur laquelle
on doit se permettre d'investir c1 c'est
une discipline où il ya de l'argent
l'équitation ne faut pas faux pas nous
ne faut pas nous gardons une dernière
problème de calendrier
vous venez ça s'est fait entendre sur
compliqué ça économique
3-5 peu exposé au japon pour un problème
aussi avec le site est ce que vraiment
au château de versailles ils sont ils
sont peut-être pas si contente que ça
que nous de voir arriver une compétition
comme ça dans la cour du roi
je pense que c'est c'est d'abord
dommageable pour la ville de versailles
qui avait il ya une occasion qui avait à
l'époque une occasion fantastique de
lier de lier un patrimoine culturel et
sportif
parce que versailles c'est une ville
c'est une ville culturelle mais c'est
une ville sportive qui justement promeut
tous les sports tous les sports où le
maximum de sport dans son dans son sein
et là deux fois de suite les
internationaux vont perdre l'habitude de
le noter sur leur calendrier de
préparation et de participation
donc là la ville de versailles perry
perd malheureusement une belle occasion
de briller et évidemment c'est tout
laisser tous les cavaliers et tout le
public qui en seront les premiers les
premiers déçus en tout cas c'est pas
forcément de bonne augure en vue des jo
de 2024 entre le toit du vélodrome
nationale qui fuit le jumping de
versailles qui a annulé
on espère qu'on en tout cas tout
rentrera dans l'ordre dans l'est dans
les prochains mois je vous propose
maintenant de parler et de golf la
fédération française annoncé vouloir
créer un pôle élite pour les meilleurs
jeunes golfeurs de france à l'horizon
2020 pour cela un lieu a été ciblé le
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
le projet prévoit notamment une salle de
sport une aire d'entraînement au petit
jeu ainsi qu'un centre d'accueil pour 30
à 40 golfeurs coût total de l'opération
près de 4 millions d'euros nous l'avons
nous avons rejoint christophe muniesa
par téléphone le directeur technique
national de la fédération française de
golf il nous explique les objectifs de
ce nouveau pôle
c'est de continuer évidemment de tout
mettre en oeuvre pour permettre à des
joueurs français d'intégrer le top 50
le top 30 mondial et deux prétendre aux
sélections des futurs ryder cup ou
solesmes cup avec en ligne de mire
l'objectif de paris 2024 et d'essayer
évidemment dit d'aller chercher deux
médailles
la question sur ce thème pensez vous que
cette mesure peut améliorer le niveau du
golf en france
oui oui pas de débat aujourd'hui pas de
duel vierge chevallier vous qui êtes
spécialiste golf évidemment obligé de
dire oui parce que c'est un c'est un
projet derrière lequel vous étiez au
courant ça vous a un petit peu surpris
on en parle depuis longtemps en fait la
fédération et le monde du golf ont pas
en parle depuis un certain nombre
d'années on court derrière le derrière
le fameux champions le cham le fameux
porte drapeau français qui durera depuis
des années et des années
c'est un moyen d'arriver à développer le
golf a développé les vocations et de
créer des nouveaux joueurs
ça n'est pas le seul c'est pas assez pas
c'est pas ce moyen unique qui fera en
sorte que le golf pour reprendre une
voix un petit peu sur l'expansion
notamment du nombre de licenciés mais
c'est évidemment un
un point positif a souligné parce que
nos champions actuels donc les
différents propre drapeau sur les dix
dernières années les victor dubuisson
les alexander les villes et les mecs
lorenzo-vera pour ne citer qu'eux et
leurs goûts et leurs glorieux anciens
des d'ailleurs s'entraîner tous un petit
peu à différents endroits sur différents
golf & resort de las de france là avec
un golf national qui désormais briller
sur la scène internationale depuis la
ryder cup depuis l'open de france même
si même si on a quelques quelques
troubles la maintenant dans le dans
l'avenir du de l'open de france
les tous les regrouper au golf national
déjà c'est s'assurer d'avoir la
meilleure une des meilleures surfaces
sportives d'entraînement golfique qui
soit de réunir les plus grands
professionnels que ce soit les pros les
administratifs aussi les préparateurs
mentaux les préparateurs physiques
c'est un gage sûrement sûrement de
succès et de toute façon c'est un c'est
un projet à pousser et à encourager pour
qu'on puisse réellement avoir un ou
plusieurs champions français qui dure
les espagnols l'ont fait avant nous les
scandinaves l'ont fait également ça
donne des résultats
donc on puisse on va pouvoir maintenant
croiser les doigts pour que notre
champion français puissent et nos
champions français et françaises
puissent émerger
je rappelle que le premier français au
classement mondial est alexander levy
il est 100e mondiale ça pique hélène
c'est forcément positif et oui toute
façon c'est l'occasion de rajeunir aussi
un petit peu tout ça de d'apporter le
golf a peut-être une génération donc
plus jeune est d'aller chercher les
meilleurs parmi les jeunes pour
finalement peut-être trouvé
nouveaux talents et puis poussé ces
nouveaux talents à devenir des grands
noms et finalement arrivants classement
comme c'est son cas mais voilà on peut
pas dire que c'est pas une bonne chose
c'est forcément envie de développer le
golf gens ça peut créer une émulation
nous a fait entre tous ces gens tout à
fait puisque aujourd'hui on a les
meilleurs joueurs qui sont éclatés un
peu l'un différents clubs en france et
forcément forcément dans leurs clubs
respectifs
ce sont les meilleurs donc au niveau de
la progression c'est parce qu'on fait de
mieux alors que là si on regroupe les
meilleurs joueurs de france mais ça va
tirer le groupe vers le haut et le
niveau vers le haut forcément puisqu'ils
vont pouvoir se confronter entre eux au
niveau du golfe ras le c est obligatoire
en main il y aura des résultats et
s'attirera le niveau vers le haut ça y
est c'est indéniable je pense qu'il faut
ajouter c'est que un pôle national comme
celui qui est en projet actuellement au
greffe nationale ça permettra aussi de
futurs futures graines de champions et
championnes d'éviter entre guillemets ou
alors d'avoir une alternative de d'aller
se former aux états unis par exemple
parce qu'actuellement c'est ce qui se
passe pour la plupart des des grandes
joueuses des grands joueurs en étant
devenir français des salaisons de plus
ils ont ils ont cette organisation là
ils ont cette organisation là ils ont
aussi la culture évidemment ils ont là
ils ont là ils ont la mode du gulf et
l'esprit du golfe aussi chevillée au
corps il ya beaucoup plus de pratiquants
aussi là bas mais ils ont ils ont cette
volonté de professionnaliser et de
donner toutes les chances aux futurs
champions de pouvoir éclore en
s'entraînant et en étant en étant non
pas en vase clos mais justement de
pouvoir glaner un petit peu toutes les
bonnes expériences de ces vieux de ces
vieux de ses anciens joueurs et et pro
qui vont pouvoir leur apporter
expérience mentale et physique et
technique très bonne chose il ya du
jarrier j'imagine que vous êtes aussi
conquis par cette initiative
oui parce que comme ça peut créer un
chiffre en une phrase une phrase chéri
d'autres
notre bon gens je pense que tout a été
dit sur ce plateau
mais oui bien sûr ce type de
regroupement permet permet il ya à peu
près la même chose pour le tennis
français à roland garros
voilà mes et puis dans le cyclisme c'est
à saint quentin ne marche pas encore
pour le tennis français
parce que en fait il ya une belle
demi-finale de vicat publie oui à l'open
d'australie et le mail preuve d'une
preuve du sportif français c'est que on
a pas on n'a pas les crocs quand quand
vous êtes un jeune candide un jeune
gamin de 18 20 ans vous n'avez pas enfin
aujourd'hui on vit en france on vit avec
une avec une cuillère une cuillère en
argent et du coup on n'a pas le l'envi
on ne naît pas avec 7,7 ce fighting
spirit cyber donner des moyens à ces
jeunes d'avoir ce fighting spirit
je pense qu'on est je pense qu'on est
simplement couver dans toutes les dans
toutes les structures dans que ce soit
au niveau d'éducation nationale que ce
soit dans tout est rendu trop facile et
dès qu'il ya la moindre difficulté qui
se présentent et quand on est trop jeune
et bien on baisse les bras et ça je
pense que c'est
c'est une vraie une vraie problématique
une vraie problématique française
culture aille mais bon après je dois me
tromper mais quand je vois je vais
bouffer son nom mais c'est mehdi baala
qui est allé s'entraîner pendant des
années avec les éthiopiens pour devenir
le meilleur sur le 3000 m steeples je me
dis c'est qu'il ya une raison voilà et
ce garçon il avait il est bien là où je
suis droitier le musée va être par
contre c'est peut-être oui enfin voila
mais je précise que j'ai certainement
inversée de droit 2 3 sur voilages
exactement manger de 3,2 les trois
informations dans le truc mais voilà il
ya des sportifs qui sont obligés de
s'expatrier pour pouvoir réussir et moi
quand je vois sur le golf que le
meilleur français au filet seulement en
file et au delà de la 100e place
mondiale alors centièmes il est juste
100e d'accord et micro
quand je vois le nombre
d'infrastructures qui peut y avoir juste
en ile de france
ou alors je me mets les plus loin
juste a dit un col en randonnée avec
victor dubuisson qui était dans les 12
15 meilleurs joueurs européens qui en
2014 il revient oui mais enfin mais
maman qui est infrastructure je me dis
comment c'est possible qu'on ne sort pas
plus de donc en effet il devait devait
manquer cette structure pour pouvoir
permettre aux meilleurs d'émerger en
effet comme vous entraîner à droite à
gauche mais vous avez pas vous avez
peut-être le meilleur préparateur mental
ne vous est pas le meilleur préparateur
physique
vous n'avez pas le meilleur préparateur
technique donc là ils vont être tout le
monde va être au même endroit et donc
tout le monde bénéficiera des meilleurs
conseils rapidement la fédération
française germes de vient de communiquer
d'ailleurs en disant que en comparant ce
qui s'était passé ou en allemagne par
exemple ou en espagne avec des champions
qui tracte en gros la scène médiatique
mais qui font face ces pays là font face
à une baisse de la licence du nombre de
licenciés pratiquants donc ainsi sur le
fait que ce ne soit pas systématiquement
corrélées
en revanche ça mérite d'être d'être
tentée de toute façon au moins en france
pour un petit peu à guérir la culture et
la culture de la gagne et du mental donc
on valide un beau projet à 4 millions
d'euros au golf national de
saint-quentin 10 4 millions d'euros mais
oui on va passer maintenant notre page
coup de projecteur désolé de vous couper
dans ce coup de projecteur de la voile
si vous voulez connaître les sensations
d'un skipper pendant un vendée globe ce
film peut vous intéresser le navigateur
versailles et éric bellion va sortir le
13 février prochain son film baptisé
comme un seul homme qui retrace son
parcours sur son vendée globe 2010 est
en totale immersion regardez la bande
annonce
que c'est bon vision mondiale comme moi
bateau tout heureux
[Musique]
j'ai abandonné 100 fois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est
enfin j'ai cassé mon safran et l'illégal
c'est du gros gros dégâts
[Musique]
si demain s'arrête je sais pas
en poule dont
je voulais rentrer en ce sens que
c'était merveille
où
j'ai trouvé ce que je cherchais
j'ai aucun regret mais en tant qu'homme
quel est au delà de ce que je pensais
[Musique]
je crois pas je pleure jamais
les amoureux
[Musique]
j'ai envie c'est une réaction sur cette
bande annonce vient d'être un beau film
il est fabuleux c'est à dire ô combien
1h25 une running away du normes et
règles ses lacets enfin la règle banal
au sol a quand même ça va ma vie j'étais
coup d'oeil quand j'ai demandé à la
production qui vous envoient des tic
hier il est bien perche et je pense
qu'en tant notre ami vendée globe c'est
pas la route du rhum en anglais c'est ça
sur la route du rhum il avait rendu rami
s'improviser la course ont descellé
installant le plus lentement possible
pour prendre du recul alors que le
vendée globe il avait vraiment il y
avait la compétition en effet la course
oui oui la colère on voit qu'il est
motivé e siècle on voit qu'il est chaud
show papa
le film doit osciller entre les moments
où il est désespéré les moments où il
est au bout du bout de ses nerfs et le
moment où il est complètement craqué on
a interviewé éric bellion va l'écouter
tout de suite
il les a présentées jeudi 24 janvier ce
film à versailles on écoute donc c'est
tout ce qui se passe quand on perd le
bateau de vue et jusqu'à ce qu'on le
redécouvre et donc c'est tout ce
cheminement intérieur le fait d'aller au
delà de sa peur de se rencontrer et
j'essaye de le raconter avec le plus de
sincérité possible je crois que que des
moments très forts
c'est ça c'est une aventure ultime moi
j'avais jamais fait de solitaire avant
de partir sur le vendée globe
donc tout est une découverte chaque jour
est une aventure un film qui a été
plébiscité par le public versé on écoute
les réactions c'est fin c'est quelqu'un
d'assez original et je trouve que c'est
sympa de pouvoir nous faire partager ce
qu'il a vécu la difficulté de la course
comme ça c'est 2 c'est pas partager ces
moments là il a eu une approche de ce
tour du monde avec une philosophie
finalement sur sa façon d'appréhender
ces difficultés sa relation avec son
bateau sa relation de la solitude ça me
parle beaucoup
la question sur ce thème comprenez vous
cette démarche avec ce film oui ou non
est déjà d'accord non mais moi je suis
d'accord pas d'accord avec non mais je
pense que de toute façon c'est tout à
son honneur ou doit partager ça et vous
disais c'est une découverte pour lui de
faire un voyage comme ça en solo on
prenait ça demain oui oui non je j'ai
mal je jette en train de regarder les
deux la perturber par eric besson c'est
du n'importe quoi mais non moi je suis
tout à fait
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'aura jamais
l'occasion dix nous qu'on pourra pas non
plus voir mis en reportage les rien
puisque reportage on n'est jamais seul
les y tourner lui-même en plus on voit
les réactions en direct et je pense
qu'il ya il ya possibilité de beaucoup
rire et en même temps de 2 d'être très
étonné de ce qu'on peut vivre non dans
une course pareille c'est il a tout à
fait raison de partager c'est une chance
il ya du guerrier
il n'y a pas de vieux on est d'accord
donc non mais c'est super sympa
justement de pouvoir permettre aux gens
de rentrer dans son intimité
moi ce que j'aimerais aussi c'est que ce
soit et avec un autre parce que comme on
sait que c'est déjà un personnage qui
est un peu vain qui je pense que il doit
y avoir deux personnages dans sa vie
c'est à dire que le sait l'homme de tous
les jours que vous allez pouvoir
rencontrer qui doit être très très sympa
comme on a pu voir sur 1 on a pu voir
sur l'interview et je pense que dès
qu'il est sur son bateau il ya un truc
qui se passe et il sort de son corps
donc vous sur le vélo comme moi sur mon
vélo tout à faire mais on est
entièrement d'accord je peux être dans
des états second quand quand je suis sur
sur mon vélo et j'en suis et j'en suis
très très fier mécénat mais c'est vrai
c'est des moments c'est des moments où
on s'en fout de ce qu'on peu de ce que
les gens peuvent penser de nous et et
moi je suis premier à faire le con quand
je suis sur mon nouveau vélo drogue bien
sûr tout à fait je suis là pour m'amuser
moi je suis c'est le vélo c'est pas que
bien sûr il ya des moments où il va
falloir être super sérieux et où la
falloir aller chercher un résultat
mais il l'a fait sur le sur le vendée
globe en terminant 11e mais mais mais
voilà je veux dire c'est à la base c'est
prendre du plaisir et donc de pouvoir le
partager
et bien entendu pour lui et j'espère que
ça va lui permettre de pouvoir prendre
un peu d'argent pour pouvoir faire
d'autres projets d'autres projets pourra
partir par la suite directement des
projets de tours du monde pendant trois
ans pour rencontrer les populations
c'est encore un projet je suis même pas
sûr son projet bon bien sûr il ya
peut-être un peu d'argent qui va rentrer
mais je suis sûr qu'à la base quand il y
as pensé passer devant ce départ vu des
bons
et voilà il a filmé peut-être en se
disant comme ça gênant il était parti
vraiment dans le fait de faire un film
il avait 2 go pro qui recharge et au fur
et à mesure il est revenu avec 50 heures
d'imagés ou de scènes non mais voilà je
pense qu'il avait peut-être le projet
transmettre etc mais pas forcément de
dans le but de gagner de l'argent n'est
rien mais vraiment peut-être l'amener
aux jeux soient là on sent qu'il ya ce
côté là il veut partager sans filtre
sans rien ça aurait pu perturber pendant
sa course
pierre chevalier s'il n'est pas ici les
parties pour ça non je pense pas c'est
c1 je trouve ça hyper frais comme
parfois se joue au millimètre en soi
mais là on est plus à posteriori c'est à
dire que là il montre par exemple un
baume à safran qui est cassé cassé en
deux ou un bout de ma il met le doigt
sur la difficulté de la course au large
en solitaire
on a pas on n'a pas vraiment on a pas
d'image en fait d'aider des courses au
large comme le vendée globe la route du
rhum etc
on sait que c'est un canard à côté
complètement mythique et que c'est
extrêmement difficile
c'est peut être un des premiers a
rapporté autant d'imagés et autant
d'image à monter je souhaiterais les
dénature pas la course
au final on a eu pendant les années et
des années les images est ce que
finalement c'est fallait pas de ces deux
livres sur une route c'est filmé brut
brut si la la ces
et comme disait ces moments de joie et
ses moments de doute extrême des
motivations c'est un bonhomme attachant
et là là ils montrent vraiment presque
l'envers du décor et la difficulté de la
course au large de ça dénature et là
mais je pense que chaque course est
différente et les le personnage à chaque
fois est différent le la course est
différente les événements la météo tout
est différent
donc je pense pas que cette dénature la
couche je pense que ça permet de la
deûle à comprendre de de voir un petit
peu ce qui se passe et de d'imaginer un
petit peu de se projeter un petit peu
dans ce qu'il faut faut être et la force
d'état d'esprit qu'il faut avoir mais
non je trouve ça que ça dénature lnd
trois fois un petit une petite chose
elle a dit un petit peu
vous nous avez dit qu'il a pris 50
heures je crois que le vendée globe
anti-parti part pour trois mois de
mémoire c'est voilà donc 50 heures sur
trois mois ces deux joueurs de cédric
roy savait pondérée des oui mais voilà
mes donc c'était juste de mémoire
j'avais j'avais souvenir d'une course
est quand même très très long et donc on
a cinquante heures sur deux mois de
course et donc on a cinquante heures de
d'image et en plus on va en voir qu'une
heure et demie quand on va le cinéma
donc en fait on ne voit strictement rien
j'exagère un petit peu mais on ne voit
quand même pas grand chose donc quelque
part il ya encore énormément à faire
découvrir et je pense que ils peuvent
encore en sortir des films et des films
et on y lit encore largement de quoi
parler
sur le champion des globes et sur les
courses en solitaire dernière question
jean est ce que ça peut susciter des
vocations
certains versets diront peut-être en
voyant le film de derrick bellion je
vais me lancer dans la course au large
oui c'est vrai oui certainement et
certainement parce que là on voit
vraiment la difficulté est une course
comme celle du vendée globe de
l'intérieur donc ça c'est des choses
qu'on avait encore jamais vu après si le
cas de ce collier un peu quand même
parce que il perdu de vue le bateau
abandonné
je sais pas mais bon il est bien guéri
mais non c'est fantastic voyage au
brésil 2 mai mais c'est c'est bien ce
qui fait d'ailleurs penser en formule 1
il ya bien deux caméras à l'intérieur on
voit bien pilote aussi qu'il était
vivant
nos clientes cette immersion aussi dans
d'autres sports a vendu j'aimerais que
la formule où elle coule
oui j'aimerais te j'aimerais qu'il tient
dans l'année aussi au rugby d'histoire à
spa son d'emmêler reste restant bda
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a même
des vidéos images non on n'a pas fini on
a déjà gagné si vous avez dans l'oeuvre
du tour de france dans le peloton du
tour de france on a aussi des images
donc voilà la technique nous permet donc
il faut le faire non non je vais pas me
couper de terminer on passe maintenant
notre page débats des écrans des partis
qui se joue à la dernière seconde
bienvenue sur un tournoi de heath porte
sur le jeu à houston exactement je coupe
pour ça un rendez vous très intéressant
organisée à l'hôtel de ville de
versailles ce samedi 26 janvier ce je
considère aujourd'hui comme un sport à
part entière dans ce tournoi versailles
on pouvait trouver un mickaël leleu
alias maverick l'un des meilleurs
joueurs français en activité il s'est
lancé dans la discipline il ya quatre
ans comme un athlète de haut niveau les
coûts de sa réaction au micro de tv 78
j'ai pas vraiment la presse sports mais
il ya beaucoup de similitudes c'est à
dire qu'on s'entraîne beaucoup on
analyse nos matches être capable d'être
concentré tout le long d'un match et
même de plusieurs matches qu'on doit
jouer plusieurs sur une journée c'est
pas toujours quelque chose facile même
bien boire entre les matchs etc
ces deux réflexes que tout le monde m'a
pas et qui sont très importants qu'on
veut faire la différence au tous niveaux
la question sur ce thème le hisse porte
est il déjà un vrai sport non pas des
manuels aujourd'hui vous avez décidé de
découper - excusez le jeu est d'acord
gens en avez vous ce n'est pas un vrai
sport alors on avait fait le débat si
l'on aimerait déjà fait le débat sur ce
plateau sur ce plateau pour le bridge
voilà
voilà pour le bridge au bout de souffle
et pour le bridge alors pourquoi je dis
non parce que pour moi lorsqu'il n'ya
pas d'effort physique
on ne peut pas alors c'est toujours le
sénat mais le problème est là qui vont
nous sauter dessus
espérons qu'ils soient pas trop gaillard
mais pour moi il n'ya pas l'époque
d'efforts physiques j'ai du mal à
pouvoir dire que c'est un sport à part
entière
pourtant il a dit qu'il fallait bien
s'hydrater entre celle en partie oui ils
ont même un long ballet l'accord alors
si vous hydrater un la boj veut coller
des sports ou et hydrate non là je crois
pas dire non mais bien sûr quelle
opération puisque les échecs le bridge
entraîne les jeux de cartes fait bien
sûr qu'elle la concentration que il ya
une fatigue qui est différente
il ya eu mise à part une hydratation
mais pour moi j'ai du mal à associer sao
mon support voilà c'est c'est plutôt une
discipline pour moi qu'un sport mois le
cas je pour moi l'image du sport c'est
un effort physique c'est physique
cela dit là où il ya une déroute des
corrélations c'est l'utilisation de la
machine c'est à dire que c'est bien un
ordi en face il ya un jeu vidéo et il
faut a priori faire la meilleure
performance s'en tirer sans tirer le
sentirais aucun avantage de la machine
elle même je fais un parallèle avec
l'équitation avec un on a un cheval et
un cavalier il ya il ya une justement
une quintessence entre les deux et puis
les lecavalier va tirer le meilleur
parti de son de son cheval il ya il ya
une vraie osmose entre les deux là j'ai
du mal à voir le lien entre eux le
joueur lui de heath porte son ordinateur
il maîtrise parfaitement sa manette
comme si vous voulez c'est le plus
complet sur le local soit habile il faut
qu'il soit habile mais ça ne repose que
sur on va dire des réflexes ou un
intellect à ma télé qui est
effectivement une préparation mais pour
moi ça ne peut pas être un sport à
partir du moment où il n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas de dépassement de y'a pas des
passeports automobile et orange sport
automobile par exemple guerre voilà
électronique il ya une voiture il ya des
équipes autour
gg je suis coincé par un sport pour vous
ainsi 6,1 à 6,6 et vont tomber
c'est physique allier la dépense
physique pour autant oui il est là la
préparation c'est pas la même chose
maîtriser son sa mallette même dans la
comparaison avec le bridge
je pense que même si le bridge on a du
mal à considérer ce soit un vrai sport
parce qu'il ya pas de confrontation
physique
il ya quand même une confrontation
d'equipe il ya des stratégies alors que
la wii je reviens ce que tu disais on
est face à une machine on doit faire le
meilleur temps la meilleure performance
ou voire dépasser voilà un score mais il
n'y a pas de y a pas d'interaction n'y a
pas de la stratégie entre plusieurs
partenaires
oui bon sur ce je la mets sur d'autres
jeux c'est possible ouais mais j'ai pour
moi c'est pas le fait qu'ils aient la
machine et qui est ce voilà ce ce milieu
au faso
comment dire ce juste et joystick oui le
rsa mais c'est cette cette machine au
milieu c'est cet univers au milieu c'est
ça pour moi ça éloigne du sport on n'est
pas dans la confrontation vraiment
physique ou mentale en one to one
voilà là pour moi il ya comme un mur au
milieu et
et qui fait une séparation avec les jets
pourtant le hisse porte est considéré
comme un sport depuis la fin des années
90 lorsque sont apparus les premières
compétitions sur internet
est-ce qu'on a des courbatures quand on
fait du sport on va même côté chimie qui
le côté endorphines
quand on fait une bonne sortie en course
à pied une bonne sortie en vélo un gros
match de rugby on sort avec un certaine
une certaine forme de bien-être et de d2
dépassement et de dépense physique
notamment
et là je suis pas sûr qu'après un match
de esport sont soit vraiment je pense
qu'on est complètement complètement
abrutis l'état d'abrutis de je ne porte
pas de jugement bien sûr les meilleurs
joueurs
pour information irvoas pour information
les meilleurs joueurs jouent dix heures
par jour et six jours sur sept
la plupart du temps voilà ce sont plutôt
des jeunes il faut il faut le dire entre
18 et 22 à bord on ne doit pas avoir la
pour pouvoir comprendre ce type
d'activité je vois la jeune homme pour
lequel je pense que voilà avec cette
idée du jury oui j'ai du mal à dire que
le mettre derrière un écran pour pour
passer du temps à jouer un jeu et a joué
un jeu vidéo
puis sept puis s'être
comparer ou puissent être intégrées au
fait de se dire que je fais du sport
pour moi faire du sport c'est ce que
disait c'est ce que disait tout à
l'heure les gens tout à l'heure c'est et
se dépasser c'est transpirer c'est être
essoufflé ces être fatigué c'est avoir
des courbatures
c'est après après je suis complètement
complètement d'accord que ils ont un
entraînement une préparation mais pour
moi c'est pas ce route même parfois en
équipe i c'est bien je me mets dans des
maisons oui les joueurs plusieurs jours
mais ils font sinon mais voilà il ya il
ya un moment où on ne peut pas comparer
ça à un 100 m des jeux olympiques et
parce qu'il ya 400 mille joueurs et les
chevilles et en france et plus de 1000
professionnels qui gagne vraiment leur
vie du jeu vidéo
vous êtes plus que dans certains sont
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose qui est très très accessible et
les consoles vidéo et cgt oui bien sûr
il y en a il y en a partout dans toutes
les maisons donc ça non peu
d'investissements en fin de compte que
les jeux ea sports tu devrais intégrer
les jeux olympiques aux noms qui font ce
temps déjà fait ça fait des années qu'il
ya des sports et notamment à paris qu'on
en parle pour les jo 2020 m à paris
antoine de caunes donc sport invités on
refuse on refuse de l'accession de
certaines sportives grain s on va mettre
le vide pour rouleurs de roller de
vitesse que j'ai pratiqué mais enfin il
fait partie des sports qui se fait
barbare et alors que au niveau des
vo2max l'hélice ceux qui sont atteints
par les eaux souillées par les sportifs
de haut niveau en roller de vitesse sont
quasi équivalente au comment s'appelle
aux skieurs de fond cochon qui sont déjà
très élevés dans le milieu mais sûrement
il ya beaucoup moins de téléspectateurs
que je rappelle quand même les chiffres
pour 2018 le sport électronique à
rassembler plus de 385 millions de
téléspectateurs à travers le monde
c'est plus par exemple que sur une
saison de ligue 1 de football par
exemple 8 millions de spectateurs au
stade
on peut pas lutter mais puisque roissy
85 millions de consoles de jeu quels que
soient les marques ils sont entrés dans
les maisons depuis depuis une vingtaine
d'années donc là c'est générationnel
c'est sûr nous on en a connu quelques
unes avec dédé d atari 520 est aidée
comme au dehors enfin ce genre de ce
genre de show des jeux vidéo sont sont
rentrés sont entrées dans les maisons
donc on peut pas lutter en terre en
termes d'audience notamment et en
terminant en termes d'intérêts d'intérêt
de la population
donc c'est vrai que si on essaye de ce
jeudi encore on essaye d'en faire un
sport c'est vrai que c'est vrai que le
nombre de spectateurs téléspectateurs
évidemment il est dans trets et non je
veux bien aimé alors on fait les
conflits ou de copeaux de pokémon vos
pokémon global oui bien sûr effectuez
également lui sport il faut marcher avec
des voix là mais pas non pas quand il
faut être derrière un écran qu'il n'y a
plus qu'à faire puisque virtuels puis on
est chez soi qu'ils ont fait mais pour
les spectateurs à regarder ça on les
voit ils sont juste là devant leur écran
il n'y a pas grand chose à vivre un
conte ya une action et je veux dire il
ya des salles il ya 17 entier qu'ils
sont en vie grâce aux dix portes cette
semaine le sujet forcément pire la vie
on ne peut pas rivaliser
je suis petite info avant de se quitter
en france le meilleur joueur français a
gagné 108 mille euros l'année dernière
en jouant au jeu de cours de combats
counter strike je vais jouer voilà cent
mille euros sur une année
tiens donc plus que certains pour lui
l'athlète qui des fois par un parfois
pendant des années des années de la
lutte
c'est la fin de cette émission va
terminer par une citation de l'un des
meilleurs joueurs de l'histoire du
hockey cette saison
l'américano canadien wayne gretzky vous
ratez 100% des tirs que vous ne tentez
pas je vous laisse méditer sur cette
phrase à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
oui